over five years after Danny Masterson's
rape allegations surfaced his former
That 70s Show co-star Ashton Kutcher
breaks his silence the actor opens up to
Esquire in short it's complicated
Kutcher wants Masterson to be found
innocent of the charges brought against
him but at the same time doesn't want
his friend to get off the hook quote I
wholesale feel for anybody who feels
like they were violated in any way
in 2017 Masterson was hit with multiple
sexual assault accusations which he
denied at the time he and Kutcher were
co-stars on another sitcom the ranch
what what what are you talking about
when you sit with your friends and you
know when their sentences are and are
about to end in the wake of the
allegations Netflix fired Masterson his
character rooster written off
so you got
two choices
either take that bag and disappear or
you could just disappear in 2020 he was
charged with a sexually assaulting three
women between 2001 and 2003. as Kutcher
sees It ultimately I can't know I'm not
the judge I'm not the jury I'm not the
D.A I'm not the victim and I'm not the
accused with that in mind Kutcher
concludes I don't have a space to
comment I just don't know as for
Masterson's Court Saga it's still
ongoing in December the deadlocked jury
led to a mistrial but in the New Year
prosecutors plan to retry Masterson also
in 2023 a notable absence from this
reunion hello Michael hey girl it was
like super nostalgic and really odd like
going back into the basement like the
fact that that happened is insane
Masterson's character Hyde was the only
OG absent from Netflix's reboot that 90s
show parents can watch her were you not
here with me in the 70s they are not the
best Watchers with Kutcher's comments
that makes two That 70s Show cast
members to speak out the other Topher
Grace
I'm doing an impression well you suck at
Impressions back in 2018 he said of
Masterson's allegations quote I hesitate
to say that I never saw any of that
behavior because I feel like it sounds
like I'm defending him but the truth is
I never saw any of that stuff as for
Kutcher's relationship with Masterson
today he tells Esquire they remain in
touch and the reason he's waited to
share his reaction he's mindful of
Masterson's eight-year-old daughter
Fiona his daughter's a good like a
couple months older than my daughter
quote someday his child is going to read
about this jury selection for
Masterson's new trial is set for March
29th
foreign